vous pensez qu'un jour la planète sera
dirigée par un Conseil des Sages comme
dans le livre de science-fiction
de choses que je rêve et peut-être même
dès cette année
bonsoir
vous avez 55 ans vous êtes marié vous
êtes deux enfants vous êtes la
personnalité la plus populaire en
Grande-Bretagne et l'une des plus
populaires du monde vous êtes un
aventurier en affaires comme dans la vie
aussi bien fondateur président de Virgin
que premier à avoir traversé
l'Atlantique et le Pacifique en
montgolfière et vous avez une devise
Richard Branson s'amuser en travaillant
et travailler on s'amusant voilà alors
vous racontez votre vie dans un livre
passionnant publié chez Scali Richard
Branson l'autobiographie qui est
évidemment c'est normal avec vous déjà
un best-seller vous en avez vendu 2
millions d'exemplaires voilà alors vous
racontez votre famille votre enfant déjà
quand vous étiez petit votre mère vous
imposez des défis
à l'âge de 4 ans elle vous fait
descendre de voiture et il vous fait
finir le voyage à pied pendant plusieurs
kilomètres
elle voulait que ses enfants apprennent
à voler de leur propre ailes le plus tôt
possible
ce
jour-là
elle vous force à faire 80 km en vélo
enfin c'était vraiment terrible
comme ça maintenant il traverse
l'Atlantique et le Pacifique en
montgolfière alors vos parents avaient
avaient peu d'argent votre père était
avocat mais assez assez pauvre
finalement et souvent vous vous
retrouvez le soir en train de manger des
des tartines de saindoux
d'aller manger du pudding à la crème
anglaise si votre futur associé Nick
Powell
j'avais un
tiroir de la cuisine où je mets tout je
mettais toute mon tout ce que je
demandais
lorsqu'on a déménagé tous ces vieux
sandwichs
alors vous étiez très mauvais à l'école
vous étiez carrément un cancre en fait
vous étiez dyslexique et myope on s'en
est pas rendu compte tout de suite et
heureusement vous étiez très doué pour
le sport vous étiez capitaine en même
temps de l'équipe de football de rugby
et de cricket
c'était une façon pour vous finalement
de vous exprimer parce qu'en Angleterre
quand on est doué pour le sport on vous
pardonne d'être mauvais dans les études
le problème c'est qu'un jour vous avez
une blessure au genou le sport vous est
interdit et là vous vous réfugiez à la
bibliothèque vous découvrez les livres
et puis vous découvrirez aussi
l'écriture
j'avais quoi 15 ans à peu près et
c'était pendant la guerre du vietnamiens
à une époque où les étudiants voulaient
faire entendre leur voix
ce journal pour donner une voix aux
étudiants et voilà vous lancez un
magazine qui s'appelle student
l'étudiant en français et c'est vrai que
à travers des expériences commerciales
comme l'élevage de sapin de Noël ou
comme l'élevage de perruches vous aviez
découvert que finalement les
mathématiques ça pouvait être utile
c'était de créer un journal mais je me
suis rendu compte assez vite que si l'on
veut être rédacteur d'un magazine et
bien il faut s'inquiéter à des questions
de diffusion de fabrication du papier
publicité des choses comme ça
si je voulais être rédacteur être
éditeur également et il a fallu donc que
je me lance et que je sache additionner
un petit peu alors studante marche très
bien vous quittez le collège et le jour
où vous quittez le collège de stoh le
directeur vous dit bonne chance Branson
vous finirez soit en prison soit
milliardaire
alors c'est Peter Blake qui avait fait
la pochette de Sergent Pepper qui
illustre la couverture du premier numéro
de Student et ensuite il y a une
embrouille terrible avec John Lennon et
Yoko no parce que vous vouliez mettre un
déjà à l'époque un disque encarté dans
le dans le journal
envie de faire un single qui serait
encarté dans le journal ça c'était
l'idée de départ et puis John Lennon a
oublié de registrer la chanson donc on
avait quoi quelques cent mille numéros
du magazine mais pas de single à mettre
dedans ce qui était un peu gênant
alors au bout du compte
on a fabriqué un single mais
c'était juste John Lennon et yokono qui
avait enregistré les battements de cœur
de leur bébé mort c'est pas très
sympathique comme il dit c'était pas ce
que j'avais prévu au départ disons au
bout du compte j'ai reçu une lettre de
directeur qui m'a dit bon tout ce qui
est là
à ce moment alors c'est l'époque de la
parenthèse enchantée c'est-à-dire après
l'invention de la pilule et avant
l'apparition du sida une époque de
grande liberté sexuelle d'amour libre
vous mettez une jeune fille enceinte
elle avorte et là vous créez un conseil
pour les pour les étudiants
moi j'avais quoi 16 ans 17 ans à
l'époque et bien souvent les jeunes ne
veulent pas parler à leur médecin s'ils
ont des problèmes ils veulent pouvoir
parler
auprès d'une je sais pas d'une
association quelques des gens
indépendants qui pourront leur parler de
maladies vénériennes de ou du fait qu'il
soit homosexuel ou des filles enceinte
ou qu'ils ont besoin de contraceptif ou
que sais-je donc on a créé effectivement
ce centre qui existe toujours
alors là vous prenez conscience que vos
amis achètent beaucoup d'albums de
musique écoute de la musique et vous
décelez une opportunité commerciale
prometteuse vous décidez de vous appuyer
sur votre magazine student pour vendre
des disques à prix réduit c'est comme ça
que vous êtes rentré dans dans le
business du disque en fait par
correspondance
que la musique se vendait très cher
alors en 1970 l'entreprise se développe
très bien mais en 1971 il y a une grève
des postes c'est la catastrophe et là
vous avez l'idée de vendre des disques
dans des magasins dans des magasins
Virgin alors vous voulez vos magasins
très différents des autres dès le départ
avec un rapport très cool entre le
vendeur et le l'acheteur
que nous étions tous plus ou moins des
hippies c'était les sixties des gens
fumaient des joints ils étaient assis
sur des coussins enfin c'est un endroit
cool on pouvait vendre acheter de
l'alcool et c'était là qu'on est allé à
l'endroit sympa et en même temps vous
créez un studio d'enregistrement
c'est-à-dire que vous vous rendez compte
en fait que les Sud enregistrement ne
sont ouverts que le jour et un jour vous
découvrez que les Stones sont
enregistrés brunchuga
après leur bol de corn flakes et vous
décidez de leur donner la possibilité
d'enregistrer la nuit quoi vous achetez
un manoir à côté d'Oxford
alors il avait un studio qu'on avait
construit dans le dans la grange et la
plupart des musiciens mais bien
enregistré là à l'époque il y avait des
Stones bien sûr mais Paul McCartney un
qui d'autre Frank Zappa di pratiquer
d'autres et des médecins
[Rires]
à l'époque vous goûtez du LSD avec une
girlfriend qui s'appelle Moundy et quand
vous êtes sous LSD vous dites je voyais
une sorte de naine ratatinée avec un
rictus assassin et là vous là vous la
quittez et vous concluez que c'est un
mauvais trip et ça c'est un truc avec
lequel je suis pas d'accord dans votre
bouquin parce que on pourrait dire que
grâce au LSD vous avez vu sa vraie
nature en fait c'était une naine
ratatinée avec un cactus assassin
effectivement c'est une femme adorable
mais je l'ai vu sous un jour bizarre
est-ce que vous pensez pas que ce
jour-là vous avez vu la vérité de cette
personne
atteint avec ce qu'on voit mais
on sait séparer c'est vrai après cette
rencontre là et je l'ai je l'ai fait
qu'une fois cette expérience alors après
la vente de disques et le studio
d'enregistrement vous vous lancez en
1973 le label Virgin et là il y a ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Michael file 13 millions d'exemplaires
c'était énorme quoi c'était ça lancé
votre maison de disque
ment précédé la maison de disque parce
que Mike avait 15 ans il m'a présenté ma
passée la démo on a trouvé ça génial
mais on l'a envoyé aux autres maisons de
disque figurez-vous et aucune d'entre
elles ne voulait
signé avec lui alors on a décidé de
créer une petite maison de disque
justement pour pour publier ce disque et
après il y a eu le succès alors le
problème après ça a été de trouver
d'autres artistes et là je comprends pas
pourquoi vous laissez échapper des gens
comme tencissi Pink Floyd The Who
toute petite maison de dise quand même à
l'époque et alors il y a un truc
terrible c'est qu'un jour vous êtes sur
le point de signer die austrate vous
allez avec eux dans un restaurant c'est
intéressant je vous rappelle et c'était
la tradition dans ce restaurant de
d'offrir un joint à chaque client après
le repas
de droguer pour le faire signer alors
voilà en tous les cas il faudra attendre
les Sex Pistols pour vous faire oublier
Michael field c'est quand même beaucoup
d'aller plus tard les 7 ans 77 à peu
près
voilà et un jour alors l'histoire ne
s'arrête pas là évidemment un jour vous
faites une escapade amoureuse avec votre
second épouse dans les Virgin Island
bien entendu parce qu'il va en vacances
les Virgin Island les îles vierges et
vous découvrez l'île de Necker que vous
achetez d'ailleurs immédiatement et
c'est là que vous vous lancez dans le
transport aérien et c'est assez
extraordinaire l'histoire un jour vous
vous êtes là il y a le vol est annulé
et il y avait une cinquantaine de
passagers très malheureux très mécontent
donc on a affrêté ce vol et puis on a
annoncé sur un tableau Virgin Atlantique
39 dollars la place et bien on a vendu
tous les deux tous les billets on a même
fait un peu de bénef dessus
et en 1984 vous créerez votre compagnie
aérienne sur la ligne New York Londres
et ça vous fait drôle de voir le logo
Virgin vous dites à l'arrière de la
viande sur la queue de la viande parce
que c'est un truc qui avait été dessiné
sur une nappe de restaurant c'est comme
assez sympa de voir ce grand logo vers
John avion là alors le vol inaugural a
donné lieu à 8 heures de fiesta
au-dessus de l'Atlantique et alors il y
a un truc très drôle c'est qu'au moment
du décollage les les passagers de
l'avion avaient un retour vidéo de ce
qui se passait dans le cockpit tout
c'est vraiment et on voit les deux
pilotes qui échangent un joint donc tout
le monde se dit [ __ ] c'est horrible on
va jamais arriver au bout mais en fait
c'est un truc qui avait été tourné la
veille c'est très drôle ensuite vous
raconter vos exploits la traversée de
l'Atlantique et du Pacifique
dans n'importe quoi
vous vous frôlez plusieurs fois la mort
quand vous faites ça c'est terrible vous
prenez des risques fous quoi vous vous
retrouvez embarqué à des milliers de
kilomètres de l'endroit où vous deviez
atterrir
pourquoi
je dois dire que
j'aime beaucoup justement les défis des
challenges voir ce que je serais capable
de faire
moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à refuser un
défi lorsqu'on me le présente
et puis évidemment ça fait de la pub sur
pour Virgin maintenant le nombre Virgin
est connu dans le monde entier et puis
on a survécu comme à tous ces accidents
la marque Virgin vaut 7 milliards de
dollars donc c'est sûr que vous avez
bien travaillé sinon pour toi
alors ensuite vous raconter votre
diversification alors là c'est énorme il
y a virgin Colas Virgin direct c'est
l'assurance vie Virgin Radio vous avez
des trains Virgin books Virgin cars et
le pire évidemment c'est Virgin Galactic
Airways alors là vous allez organiser
des voyages dans l'espace et vous dites
sérieusement que d'ici à 2008 on pourra
faire les premiers voyages privés dans
l'espace pour moins de 200.000 euros
nous sommes en train de construire 5
navettes spatiales qui s'appuie sur la
technologie c'est-à-dire le premier
modèle de navette qui est
trois fois dans l'espace donc ce sont en
fait des des fusées spatiales
recyclables c'est à dire que la navette
monte à 60 000 pieds
on lâche la navette qui ensuite se lance
dans l'espace à trois fois la vitesse de
la justice
un aller-retour pour 200000 dollars
it safe c'est sûr
si vous pouviez vous le permettre est-ce
que vous le feriez la plupart d'entre
vous qui ne voudrait pas aller dans
l'espace
votre plus grand regret finalement c'est
de pas être arrivé à empêcher l'invasion
de l'Irak vous aviez persuadé Nelson
Mandela d'aller à Bagdad pour convaincre
Saddam Hussein de partir en exil
finalement et vous aviez deux pilotes
qui étaient prêts à Johannesburg près à
décoller avec Nelson Mandela à bord et
ça c'était le 19 et le 20 bouche a
décidé de l'invasion de l'Irak quoi
il fallait lui trouver une stratégie de
sortie
ils ont en sauvant la face parce que tu
es des centaines de milliers de gens
simplement pour avoir atteindre une
personne ça me paraissait pas calculer
très habile derrière les Français ont eu
raison mais pas les Américains et les
Anglais là-dessus
au bout du compte ce qu'on a peut-être
appris dans tout ça c'est que on a créé
cette organisation qui s'appelle dr2s et
Mandela et son épouse seront les les
fondateurs et on va trouver 12 autres
parents de cette organisation est-ce
qu'on peut espérer c'est que au bout
d'un certain temps ces aînés c'est sages
pourront peut-être empêcher certaines
guerres vous pensez qu'un jour la
planète sera dirigée par un Conseil des
Sages comme dans le livre de
science-fiction
que je rêve et peut-être même dès cette
année il y aurait
dans les villages d'Afrique vous avez
justement les sages dans lesquels on se
tourne et ce serait bien que la
communauté du monde entier puisse avoir
des gens qui soient au-dessus de la
politique au-dessus des égaux des uns
des autres qui puisse être élu je ne
sais pas par Internet par exemple des
gens qui soient disons au-dessus de tout
cela des stages vers lesquels on
pourrait se tourner 12 Nelson Mandela
des versions masculines les féminines
mais qui viendraient du monde entier de
Chine d'Amérique latine du monde entier
peut-être même d'Amérique et de et
d'Europe pour ma part moi je crois que
ce serait quelque chose qui serait très
attendu par la communauté du monde
entier
[Musique]
c'est publié chez scalin et la messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Richard
vous parlez un peu français
alors on va essayer on va faire une
interview moi il y en a parlé français
[Musique]
essayez
Richard
vous allez bien
très bien merci et toi vous avoir quel
âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avoir meilleurs souvenirs
de votre vie
oui
des enfants deux enfants
bien il y a un souvenir terrible dans
votre livre c'est cette fille chaque
fois que vous faisiez l'amour avec elle
vous aviez de l'urticaire sur la sur la
[ __ ] c'est terrible cette histoire non
mais c'est vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour donner à manger aux gens
pauvres gens l'hiver comme tous les
riches il a rien sur lui maintenant il a
de l'argent sur lui un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu